a bright and peaceful morning at the
Al-Aqsa mosque compound with
Palestinians observing Ramadan by
reading the Quran
thank God I am happy thank God I can't
express my happiness to pray at Al-Aqsa
mosque I am 50 years old and Israel
recently lifted the security ban on me
[Music]
occupied East Jerusalem
to welcome the fasting month with the
first Friday afternoon prayers
but there were long cues at military
checkpoints across the occupied West
Bank with many Palestinians waiting a
long time to pass through
they didn't let me cross to pray because
I am younger than 55. in one month I'll
be 55 I told them I want to pray they
refused they said you have to be older I
can't pray because of a one-month
difference earlier this week Israel
announced only Palestinian women
children under 12 and Men above the age
of 55 will be allowed into Al-Aqsa for
Ramadan prayers without a permit but
this wasn't the case for many
foreign they're not making it easy even
children who are one month older than 12
they refuse to let them cross they also
force their mothers to go back with them
they didn't let women or older children
with security bands to get in Israeli
forces have set up roadblocks and impose
strict measures on the way to the city
and at the Gate of the mosque with the
recent heightened tensions in the
occupied West Bank and East Jerusalem
there are concerns of an escalation of
Violence by Israeli forces against
Palestinians
of course we fear escalation but we hope
that Ramadan will be peaceful without
escalation and that Muslims will be able
to enter Al-Aqsa to pray without any
problems between Jews and
arabsa compound has been a flash point
for tensions between Palestinians and
Israelis there's also been an increase
in Israeli ultra-nationalist groups
making incursions into the compound in
recent years but despite the
restrictions many Palestinians say it's
important to be at the al-aqsamos during
the holy month of Ramadan
Al Jazeera